[Music]
time now for pft on yahoo sports peter
king and mike florio with some of the
top stories in the national football
league and it's playoff time but
sometimes teams that aren't in the
playoffs generate some news and the news
came out over the weekend that patriots
coach bill belichick would be
receiving on thursday of this week the
presidential medal of freedom from
donald trump less than a week before
trump is out of office and it created a
backlash given the events of last week
that happened at the u.s capitol
belichick issued a statement peter on
monday night that he
will not be receiving the honor and
the statement was very interesting in
how it was written in what it said and
what it didn't say but at the end of the
day belichick i think realized that it
was not going to be good for him there
were going to be a lot of people who
were upset if he went through with it
and he decided not to do it
well mike i mean you're right i think
the statement was really interesting
because it basically said it was decided
it didn't say i decided or it was my
decision
you know which would have made this a
lot clearer quite honestly
but in the end it was the only decision
and it was the right decision
because
you know
and again look i don't know that bill
belichick ever really thinks
very long into the future about these
things but
this is a bit mindful
mike do you remember when bill belichick
would not appear on camera
to
apologize for whatever role
he might have played in spy gate
and
you know he issued a statement
okay
roger goodell was under the impression
the strong impression that bill
belichick was going to stare into the
cameras and said
i don't necessarily agree with
everything in this in the charges but i
do accept my responsibility for what
went wrong i'm the captain of the ship
here and he never did that
and it really ticked off goodell
okay
and
this kind of reminds me of the same
thing
you know bill belichick now by issuing
this statement and then disappearing
never has to appear on camera to answer
any questions about it and when it is
when he is finally questioned about it
he's going to say something like my
statement stands for everything
so
when you're doing the 30 for 30 on bill
belichick's life
there won't have to be
any video of him being contrite about
spygate or of him saying here's why i
turned down
and you know the things that i saw in
that statement included uh
two that that stood out one he
specifically mentioned that he doesn't
simply represent himself he represents
his family and the new england patriots
which tells me he was getting pushback
from his family and from the new england
patriots and the patriots would have
taken a hit here it would have been far
better off for no one to ever even know
that it was a possibility quietly
decline at the time see the problem is
this was all arranged before the mayhem
of last wednesday the insurrection
others don't want to use that word i use
that word because that's exactly what it
was it was an insurrection that changes
everything somebody at the white house
put the cart in front of the horse and
said this was happening before belichick
had a chance to say no it's not or more
accurately before others had a chance to
tell him it's in his best interest in
the best interest of the team for it to
not happen and i really do think that
that he reluctantly went along with this
i think he wanted to do it i mean he's
got the strong military background he
thinks it's a big deal it's a great
honor but i think at the end of the day
he did it for the right thing because
peter this had disaster written all over
it if he had gone through with it it
would have not been good for him or the
patriots
mike the big question is what what would
it be what would it look like
three four five months from now or three
four five years from now
it just would not have been good for
bill belichick
and maybe just maybe the next president
joe biden will be the one who gives bill
belichick the presidential medal of
freedom under those circumstances he
most likely would be able to accept
without any real issues that's it for
this edition of pft
on yahoo sports thanks for some of your
time and we'll see you down the road
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports